good morning everybody
everybody hear me okay
all right good morning
i'm robert norton i'm the vice president
and general counsel of hillsdale college
i'd really like to welcome you all here
today uh this is quite an historic
occasion i don't know that there's ever
been an actual hearing of the michigan
supreme court conducted here on our
campus
as many of you know the college is the
second oldest college here in the state
of michigan
it was established in 1844 and we moved
to this location in 1852
there's many historic events that are
associated here with the college and of
course we have our high school students
here today we want to thank them for
being here we hope this is going to be
very informational for you
but ask as the college itself
um the college has been intertwined both
in the nation's history and the state's
history uh we have numerous alums that
have gone on to public service that's
something that we kind of stress here
um our students fought in the civil war
and in fact in that engagement our
students we had the highest percentage
of students that took part in the civil
war in the country and the highest
actual number of students was yale
university they were much bigger school
than hillsdale especially at that time
we were only 17 years old
so
notables in michigan history connected
to the college there was austin blair
who was known as the war governor of
michigan
he received an honorary doctorate from
the college and he later served here as
a faculty member
college president edmund burke fairfield
he helped found the republican party
some of you may know that he served as a
state senator and then as lieutenant
governor
up in jonesville there's a grosvenor
museum house that was actually the house
of the former lieutenant governor
he was also a college trustee here of
the college
some of our alumni have gone on to the
michigan state senate notables are john
c patterson in 1864
a.r chapman in 1867
h.l wood in 1869 and today eric nesbitt
a current sitting state senator is a
graduate of the college
they're alumni who also have been
involved with the michigan house of
representatives
henry v perrin in 1850
jb moore
eugene belden
g w thompson
a w westgate
eric loithauser
and andrew fink currently is a
representative and is a graduate of
hillsdale college
on the michigan supreme court we've been
honored to have joseph b moore
c.d long
walter h north and we're proud to claim
current sitting justice viviano as one
of our own as an alum of the college
justice zara is a distinguished fellow
of hillsdale college and is also our
judicial advisor to the hillsdale
college federalist society
there's only three federalist societies
at the undergraduate college level
usually federal societies are only at
law schools
quite notable here today is the presence
of former chief justice markman who's
been a professor of constitutional law
at hillsdale college for 25 years he is
a beloved and cherished professor here
those of you familiar with hillsdale
college know that the college holds dear
the founding documents but especially
those of the united states constitution
and the ability for each state to have
its own constitution
we defend the notion of constitutional
government
the hearing that will be held here today
is a great example of the robustness of
our state constitution
the court will be asked to determine the
constitutional balance
between that of law enforcement that
provides each one of us with protection
versus that of
in of individual rights
it's because the case that's before the
court today has uh the need to to define
this demarcation line previously
undefined the court will give answer and
clarity going forward
it's important to know that this case
today that we'll be privileged to
observe the hearing of
has made its way all the way through the
appellate process
most cases do not make it this far
especially for our high school students
to understand it's very few cases that
ever get to this level
most of the cases are resolved at the
trial court level and most of the legal
decisions you and i will ever feel are
going to be done at the local level
so i'm honored today to be able to
introduce the chief judge of the
hillsdale county court system and that's
our circuit court judge
for the benefit of the students here
today you may not know that circuit
judges the name implies they used to
ride on a circuit on horseback and go
from place to place
and when the circuit court judge arrived
it was a big deal basically the town
kind of closed down this is the day when
the big judge has come to town
all the important decisions that were
going to be made have been held we're
going to make these decisions now
now if you're someone who had done
something wrong and there's a strong
case against you you're not so happy
that the circuit judge is in town
because now your sentence is going to be
handed down but for the rest of the
community they wanted to see law and
order they wanted to have these cases
decided they wanted to know that justice
had been served
there's a historic house by the way over
on northwest street that still stands
today that was the home of the first
permanent circuit judge that we had it
was a judge wilson
today the circuit judges remain in place
and ours
has
her chambers and her courtroom is here
at our local courthouse they don't
travel around anymore like that
but if i may i want to tell you a little
bit about our local circuit judge sarah
lisney
she was born and raised in livonia
michigan she's been married for 34 years
to anthony lisney
she's a resident of jonesville for the
last 26 years
she has two children
eric 28 who is a surgery resident at
henry ford hospital in detroit and elsie
26 who's also an attorney she's the law
clerk for judge jan cunningham in eaton
county
she was educated at eastern michigan
university she got her law degree from
wayne state university so she was born
raised and educated right here in the
state of michigan
she practiced law for 24 years as a
practicing attorney
she joined a prestigious law firm in
bloomfield hills after her graduation
from law school then she moved to a
downtown detroit law firm decided the
big city life wasn't for her so she came
out to jonesville and she helped found a
law partnership that was known as marx
and lisney it later transformed its name
into lisney and associates
she then decided to serve the community
by running for district judge in 2014.
she was easily elected by the community
that knew her
and then when judge smith announced his
retirement she ran for circuit judge
opening and again was easily elected by
the community that knows her
and you'd think with a career track like
that you wouldn't have much time for
community service right pretty hard to
practice law you always have to be
building those hours but yet her
community involvement is pretty
impressive
she's a member of saint paul's
evangelical
evangelical lutheran church a former
sunday school teacher a council member
she's a member of the hills of bobby
lake board of directors she previously
served as a member of the fayette
township planning commission
the headwaters recreational authority
hillsdale county community foundation
board of directors
jonesville rotary where she was a past
president hillsdale county exchange club
hillsdale county intermediate school
board of education where she was a vice
president
the hospice of hillsdale county board of
directors
student home board of directors
she was even a 4-h parent a county fair
participant
and is a certified master gardener
she's exactly the kind of person that
you'd like to see over our local
judicial system i'm proud to know her to
consider to be a friend of this
community and at this time i'm going to
turn over the proceedings to judge sarah
lisney
[Applause]
that's perfect
sorry
my fault
team effort
can you all hear me
it's unusual for me to have to bend down
for a microphone we were obviously
lowering this for my my height
uh thank you bob for the introduction
and kind words and thank you to
hillsdale college for hosting this
important event
on behalf of the hillsdale county courts
i wish to welcome each of you
to today's oral arguments before the
michigan supreme court
i can't tell you how happy it makes me
to be able to say those words
how many of you either watched or know
about the tiger game from last saturday
you all know what happened right
our own miggy got his hit number 3000
right
as excited as the detroit tigers were
about that
that's my excitement for today
this is a very special day
as chief judge i was first contacted in
the fall of 2019
by the supreme court to ask if we were
interested in hosting this event we of
course said yes
immediately hillsdale college got on
board to host the event
and the planning began
my court administrator at the time chris
shane hour
became the court liaison and began
working on the many details that go into
planning an event like this it took
weeks and months the event was slated
for april of 2020.
none of us will forget what happened
during the spring of 2020 the event was
postponed it was rescheduled to the fall
of 21
it was again postponed
and as with most things the third time
was the charm and here we are today
in the meantime however
the ms shane hour has retired from
service to the county after over 40
years she agreed to come back for one
thing and one thing only and that was to
see this event through she has done so
and i am i am grateful for her efforts
in making today
successful i'd like to give her a round
of applause
we will soon be joined by the seven
michigan supreme court justices
as you can see when our supreme court
hears cases
they do so as a group
that is the opposite of the way that
trial courts operate
each county in our state has three types
of courts
a circuit court a probate court and a
district court
one judge is assigned to each court
because we work alone it's unusual for
us to come together unless there is a
special event
that is part of what makes today
noteworthy as well
here in hillsdale county we have three
local judges you've already heard that i
am the circuit judge
it's now my pleasure to introduce to you
my colleagues our probate and district
judges
first i'd like judge bianchi to stand
the honorable michelle bianchi was
elected to the probate bench in 2012 and
she has served since then prior to that
she was in private practice for many
years judge bianchi has a special
relationship with hillsdale college as
her daughter is about to graduate in
just a few weeks
next we have our district court judge
the honorable megan stiverson
judge stiverson served as our chief
assistant prosecutor and our juvenile
magistrate prior to being elected
district court judge in 2020.
thank you judge diverson
i am honored to get to introduce two of
our retired judges from hillsdale county
first the honorable michael nye
our former probate judge
judge nye is also our former state
representative he was appointed to the
probate bench in 2002
judge and i retired after many years of
service in 2012.
second the honorable donald sanderson
our former district court judge and my
predecessor at district court
judge sanderson was appointed to the
district court bench in 1978.
he served as district court judge for 36
years until his retirement in 2014.
is it possible judge sanderson that you
heard over 3 000 cases
he may be the miggy of hillsdale county
i also have the privilege of introducing
judges from our neighboring counties of
branch and lenaway first the honorable p
william o'grady is the branch county
circuit court judge
judge o'grady was elected to the circuit
bench in 2008 after serving branch
county as its assistant prosecutor and
serving as a state trooper as well thank
you judge o'grady
and then next
we have the honorable todd morgan he is
the newest judge i have the pleasure to
introduce
judge morgan was appointed last month to
the lenaway county district court
welcome to the bench
previously he was a public defender and
in private practice i know judge morgan
from when he was in private practice and
just bear with me with one more sports
metaphor he may be up for rookie of the
year
thank you
next i have a very welcome surprise for
this morning we have justice beth walker
from the west virginia supreme court
she was
placed on the bench in 2017 as i
understand it welcome thank you for
being here
and she is a hillsdale college
graduate now lastly i'd like to
recognize the rest of you
we have local attorneys we have members
of the community we have other elected
officials
we have court personnel county personnel
we have schools teachers and students
all here with us today
i believe that each of us as
michiganders and americans must have an
understanding of our system of
government
i'm thrilled that all of us will not
just be reading about what the highest
court in michigan is doing
we will be seeing and hearing it with
our own eyes and ears and increasing our
knowledge in the process
today we highlight my favorite branch of
government the judicial branch
i'm proud to be here and i hope you
enjoy this thank you
[Applause]
all right
the chief justice and justices of the
supreme court of michigan all persons
having business before this honorable
court our admirers to draw an eye and
give their attention to the court is now
sitting god save the united states the
state of michigan
these mics are hot
can you hear me can anybody hear me no
you can't now you can i just have to
talk into it a little more good morning
everyone
it is really nice to be here um
this is
uh exciting for us it's our first
community connections program in a
couple of years
we meant to be here a few years ago
and we are delighted that this is the
first place we've been able to visit
since we've been back on the road
i want to thank a few people before i
call this morning's case
our hosts and i want to welcome the
students and their teachers more than
250 students are participating in this
historic event today including the
following schools will carlton academy
hillsdale high school reading high
school hillsdale academy
camden frontier schools jonesville high
school and litchfield community schools
which is participating virtually
we are very grateful that you all are
participating in this event today
we also want to thank the hillsdale
county bar association the attorney
mentors the students the teachers and
the community members for all your
support we we appreciate all your
efforts without our local partners
this kind of program wouldn't be
possible this is the 26th time
uh the court has done this and as is is
the case with all of those previous
events
um we are very dependent on the local
bench and bar
for their support for their cooperation
for their mentorship um and and and this
county has uh stepped up with flying
colors and we're very grateful we're
also grateful to the michigan state
police and the hillsdale college campus
security department
um and this argument today is also being
live streamed so viewers can watch it
from anywhere in the world so welcome to
those of you who are watching versus
live stream
a couple of housekeeping items um with
the exception of the media and
professional photographers no one else
uh take take photographs once the
argument begins um it's distracting to
the lawyers we'd probably be fine but
it's not fair to them
um there'll be plenty of opportunities
for photos during the reception when we
when we finish
following oral argument please stay in
the courtroom you probably already know
this but for the
debriefing with the lawyers which we're
grateful to them for doing um
and uh this year we have a very special
guest moderator
our own
long-time colleague retired supreme
court chief justice stephen markman is
going to moderate the post-argument
q a he's taught constitutional law here
at hillsdale for nearly 30 years i'm
told he has never missed a class
those of us here on the stage are just
delighted to see him again it's been a
long couple years for all of us in lots
of ways but we have very much much
missed chief justice markman and we're
happy to have him
with us today
oral argument is a very important part
of the decision-making process
for an appellate court it helps us
ask the lawyers what we think are the
hardest questions in the case we've done
a lot of work getting ready for this as
as i know all of you have as well and
usually by this time we're focused on
what we think the hardest questions are
and we know that council will be able to
help us with those questions
we
look forward to all of the learning that
happens today we hope that at the end of
this event we leave you better informed
about the rule of law
about the judicial branch and about its
important role in our democracy so with
that i'm going to call the case that
we're going to hear this morning people
versus
david lucinski this is a 20-minute
argument uh mr jockens that means you
may reserve time if it works out that
way but we we like you to try and keep
track of it
good morning chief justice
if i may please the court my name is
bernard jonkins i'm here to argue on
behalf of david lucinski
the traffic stop in this matter was
invalid
pursuant to mcl 257.267b
there was no actual traffic that was
present during the stop
not only that
there was an unreasonable mistake of law
that had occurred from deputy robinson
stop in this situation
and also in the driveway this was
definitely a seizure
normal flow of traffic
a person without authority shall not
block obstruct impede or otherwise in
fear with the normal flow of vehicular
streetcar or pedestrian traffic upon a
public street or a highway
mr lucinski's car was not stationary at
the time of contact with deputy robinson
and the police
and mr liscinski actually moved his
vehicle unblocking of the theoretical
impediment at this time of the imaginary
traffic
so it brings into the general theme
that
if it doesn't interfere if it doesn't
interfere with the normal flow
then the traffic stop in this
circumstance would be a
no mr lucinski is not interfering with
the normal flow of traffic on old state
road and there is nothing in the statute
that prevents two cars
from communicating when they're not
impeding the normal flow of traffic
which this brings something to
as far as the statute is concerned
a community standard my apologies we
have to look at things uh locally
because the normal flow of traffic is
different everywhere in the united
states and it made me think of when i
was driving in here
on east ball road that that was a road
that was very similar
to the road of old state road where mr
lesinski was stopped
so on that road theoretically a car came
up to me i don't think it would have
been
impeding the normal flow of traffic at
that time
however i noticed in the distance that
there was a combine that was like up on
on the left in one of the fields there
now if a combine would have been
operating on the road going down the
road then there was good argument that
this is something that might have been
impeding traffic and controversy the
statute there
so there was no actual offense
this was an illegal stop this was
something that was an unreasonable
mistake of law by deputy robinson the
circumstance
and the statute is clear that it has to
interfere with the normal flow
of traffic not imaginary
um
was there a traffic stop at all in this
case yes your honor there was the
prosecutor is going to indicate that
there was not a stop there was
definitely a stop and i mean just let me
just
when we think of a stop
you know we think of a police car
activating its emergency lights
maybe even using the loudspeaker
directing somebody to pull to the side
of the road
but that didn't happen here did it
your honor this is distinguished from
many other traffic stops what happened
in this circumstance as deputy robinson
had followed
for some reason for impeding traffic had
followed mr lesinski and he pulled into
a driveway to visit a friend when he
exited the vehicle
got out and then there was a police car
behind that was blocking the ingress and
egress
therefore that would have that was
definitely a stop there but your client
didn't he didn't come to to rest his
vehicle didn't come to rest
at the direction of the police officer
did it
no it did not your honor however he was
not
free to leave he would not have been
able to exit
to just carry on and go into the
friend's house
possibly i don't necessarily think that
he was it was confronted by the police
officer at that point there was
definitely a seizure because he had
provided his driver's license
and there is some objectivity in as to
what is considered a seizure there in
regards to the the stop
maybe he could have went in
however in the circumstance he was
definitely prevented from entering the
home he had to produce his
identification to the officer and at
that point he wasn't free to leave if he
had uh just um parked the car parallel
to the house and not pulled in the
driveway would that have been a
distinguishing factor and then it's not
a stop at that point
i don't know if that would have been
because i mean this this has to deal
with
if he would have been free to actually
leave at that point i mean he would have
been out and parked but still at the
same time
there
he had to obey the commands of the
officers deputy robinson in this
circumstance
what are we to make of your client's uh
demeanor if you've looked at the video
he seemed pretty relaxed he was sort of
conversational with the police we know
the court of appeals found that this was
more akin to the police
sort of chatting with someone along the
street
um you know his demeanor was pretty
pretty
laid back
well that's kind of how people are there
i mean it's a country this is in reese
michigan it's a country road no one is
in a hurry to go anywhere or really do
anything
as far as him being calm
he didn't do anything wrong he had no
reason to to be high strung or to be
upset and quite frankly that's how his
demeanor is
it would be cool if that was something
that i ca i could implement in my daily
routine as far as my demeanor
i'm sorry if we get past the question of
whether there's a stop you say it's not
an unreasonable mistake of law as i
understand it justice kagan has
suggested that a reasonable mistake of
law would be whether a reasonable judge
would see it this way in this case we
have a michigan court of appeals case of
people be salters judge talbot o'connell
and cooper three judges who sat for many
years on the trial court before going to
the court of appeals and then serving on
the court of appeals and these three
unanimously concluded that these that
this would be
uh impeding traffic now even if we agree
with you that that's wrong why would why
would that not be a reasonable
interpretation here are we going to hold
our
police officers to a higher standard
than we hold judges of the court of
appeals as it relates to understanding
law
no but police officers should be held to
a little bit higher standard than a
normal citizen the uh the burden
shouldn't but
follow the decision of people these
alters if they read it wouldn't they
understand this to be in a stop and
impeding of traffic i appreciate the
reference to the unpublished opinion of
people these salters familiar with the
case
justice are however this case is more
similar to that of people the owen in
which there was an unreasonable mistake
of law that was
addressed by this court which i'm pretty
sure the court remembers it has to do
with the speed limit that was improperly
posted and an unreasonable belief
this mirrors the facts in the owen case
not the salters case in addition to that
in that case was there a court of
appeals opinion that agreed with the
officers interpretation of the law i
can't say with a degree of certainty
i don't think there was and that's why
i'm pointing to salters here there is a
court of appeals case that would
interpret this statute the same way this
officer did so
even if it's wrong would that not be a
reasonable mistake of law no it's not
because there was no traffic there was
fictitious traffic the reason for the
stop as indicated unambiguously by
deputy robinson was for impeding traffic
and pursuant to the statute there has to
be actual traffic not theoretical
traffic in the future not something that
may occur not from a combine that's
often a field that's not on the road it
has to actually impede the normal flow
and that's why the most appropriate case
to follow is also
for that of persuasive authority and
that would be that of the hanan
tennessee case where they dissect
eight different state jurisdictions as
far as to what would constitute impeding
traffic so you would disagree with
justice kagan's standard for how we
would find a reasonable mistake of law i
think that my words are being minced
there however trying to understand
where
where do you see justice kagan's
position here
i mean if if it's a reasonable judge see
would would interpret the statute that
way don't we have that here in michigan
with the salters case
a reasonable mistake of law can justify
a seizure that's under the fourth
amendment i'm sure the court will agree
with that
reasonable mistake of law can justify us
under the fourth amendment and quite a
bit suggesting just the opposite
there's nothing that can be gained from
a holding
and wish it would turn
the burden over to the citizen this is
basically passing the buck onto
the police being able to use as a sword
and shield the hind case council we
could we could agree with you about all
of the facts we could even agree with
you about the interpretation of the
statute and there's still this
um you you might think of it as a legal
fiction that
we judge the reasonableness of a police
officer's mistake
by what
direction the police officer might have
had about the law before the stop
happened right and the only direction
was the psalter case
i'm not i i i'm not going to sit here
and tell you i'm sure that the officer
reads every unpublished case of the
court of appeals but the way the supreme
court tells us to think about reasonable
mistake of law is to look at that as one
of the signaling devices to help us
figure out whether it's reasonable or
not
does that make sense i understand that
however with the analogy of that case
chief justin chief justice i don't agree
with the the logic there i don't believe
that there is a reasonable mistake of
law into this fact pattern so the answer
is the court of appeals got it so wrong
in salter that
um
the officer should have known that this
was not uh that that this that there
wasn't a valid reason to to pull behind
your client in my humble opinion yes
i mean i believe that that valid reason
had extinguished as soon as the the
traffic kept going there was no reason
for the officer to follow at that point
does it matter that the officer when he
pulled your client over or pulled behind
him in the driveway um didn't mention
anything about the traffic what happened
in the street and instead mentioned
concern about drugs
well
that's what he indicated is he was
concerned again something else that i
thought that was fictitious i find that
suspect that none of that was mentioned
at all
it didn't appear to be something that
resembled anything as far as a
reasonable stop as far as the officer
not mentioning that
you know for all
it's not like he had approached him and
said hey you know we're
selling girl scout cookies would you
mind buying some for my daughter here
if the officer would have wanted to do
that more than likely
he would not have been blocking the
ingress and egress on old state roads so
mr lesinski would not be able to leave
this was it was definitely a police
confrontation that
what wasn't just meant to be a general
conversation
that the way that the
police car was positioned it was
definitely blocking
and i can only imagine what would have
happened if mr lucinski would have
actually attempted to leave then we
might have also been here for resisting
obstructing or something like
can that turn to the question of whether
this is a seizure
i this definitely was a seizure because
part of part of what determines a
seizure is the objective objectivity in
regards to the actual person and that's
not enough there has to be something
that's a little bit more in this
circumstance
there is an officer that was on a
driveway on private road
blocking the ingress and egress
mr lesinski was approached by the
officer and obeyed the officer's
commands what what what what command did
the officer give to your client he
wanted to ask for his driver's license
that's a question that's not a command
right well if he would if you would have
like flown in the middle digit or
something like that i'm pretty sure that
that would have been something else he
was following that direction of the
officer asking for someone's driver's
license or if they have identification
that's definitely a command it's not
optional when you have someone in a
uniform that's going to
the cases that deal with seizures talk
about
you know we have fact patterns where
a police car turns its lights on or
where an officer
commands somebody to stop
or to halt
in this situation
it appears as though the officer pulled
into the driveway like any ordinary
citizen could
or would
and asked your client some questions
what facts would you
urge us to to focus on
in terms of why your client felt
additional pressure not just the
pressure that any one of us might feel
to respond to a police officer there's
always some pressure the court the
supreme court united states supreme
court has recognized that there's always
some baseline of pressure that
most people would feel to be trying to
be helpful to a police officer
but the inquiry for us is what
additional
pressure was placed on your client why
did why why do you believe your client
felt
uh that he was compelled
to stay there and to answer the
officer's questions as opposed to
continuing into the house
looking at the totality of the
circumstances
my client generally likes to follow the
law
he was obeying what was directed from
the officer
it was approached to ask for his id but
in addition to that just so we're clear
the officer never told them to stop
correct that is correct and the officer
never told him he couldn't leave
right
officer also blocked the ingress and
egress him the officer alone i know the
court is aware just because it says that
is not free to leave doesn't mean the
person feels for you to believe there
are a lot to do with the objectiveness
there are a lot of cases a lot of cases
deal with the blocking of a car
um
most of them seem to seem to be where
the police cruiser
is parked you know in a way that a
normal car could not be parked and and
directly behind a vehicle preventing it
from
leaving
this situation as i see it is a little
bit different the as i understand the
facts the police cruiser was about a car
length behind your client's car is that
right
it wasn't your regular traffic stop and
it was about a car length that was
behind it when it was pulled into the
driveway and then the way that the car
was positioned you could not leave the
driveway
but the police cruiser was about a car
length behind is that right in other
words it wasn't right up against your
client's car
i don't believe that it was it was right
behind i believe was about a car length
but he was still a uniformed officer
that exited the vehicle and now i'm
aware i'm aware of those facts the
lights were not emergency lights were
not engaged though correct that's
correct
the um
i'm sort of thinking of it in terms of
whether this officer did what an
ordinary citizen would have done
if they wanted to talk to your client
it'd be normal for people that's how a
driveway is used right there's case law
that talks about
you know this is how a driveway is used
if you want to approach someone and
speak to them you'd pull onto their
driveway and get out of your car and
approach them is that that that's pretty
much what happened here right
yeah the the individual was a uniformed
police officer in a police car that had
blocked the entrance ingress and egress
so that's why you just feel free to
leave let me ask you this question
because i'm not familiar with this road
was this the type of road where the
police officer could have parked on the
road and walked up to the house in other
words was there parking on the street or
is this i believe there could have he
could have parked off
where it would have been uh
closer to a shoulder it's a dirt road
where there's one lane one direction one
lane the other direction he could have
definitely pulled up and
without going into a bank he could have
parked on that road
one last factual question in terms of
blocking egress
was it possible for your client to
maneuver his car around the police
cruiser if he had gone off the driveway
and into the grass
possibly
but i think that that would have also
initiated some other things as well
i mean we don't we don't know that right
if it's possible the officer would have
let him go he would have had to went off
into grass and then i don't know how
safe that would have been
okay i'd like to draw your attention to
the case of o'malley versus city of
flint a sixth circuit case that i find
persuasive and it's not cited in either
party's brief
there the police officer saw a chevy
tahoe that he suspected of being used to
impersonate a police car and the officer
followed it
the tahoe parked in a residential
driveway and the driver got out of the
car
after the driver got out of the car
the officer pulled into the driveway
behind the tahoe
and approached the person and asked if
he could speak to him
the court there found that this was not
a seizure a reasonable person would have
felt free to continue walking even after
the officer's vehicle was parked behind
the unoccupied tahoe that seems to be on
all fours with this case
why should we not find this six circuit
case persuasive in concluding that there
was not a seizure
well for one the reason why the
individual was being followed was for
something that didn't exist there was no
impeding traffic in addition to that
this was an actual blocking of an
ingress egress in a driveway it wasn't a
parking lot in addition to that
also this is a residential driveway here
as well in o'malley
the circumstance is a little bit
different i don't know if that was in
the city or country or whatnot i'm
presuming it was in more of a rural or
an urban area and why wouldn't that
matter
because of custom which that goes back
down into where we uh began at this
justice zara
as far as where impeding traffic would
go which is why we're here why this
started out
there has to be some sort of
interruption of the normal flow of
traffic as far as the seizure is
concerned there's cases that do
indicate that
something has to be something an
additional it has to be you know if a
person was blocked in or if a person had
to give his id
does that
follow upon answer any any query that
you had i would like to save a little
bit of time for a bottle if that's
possible
but it's fine with me you have 59
seconds if you sit down really fast
counsel
please court eric wonick chief assistant
prosecutor for tuscola county on behalf
of the people of the state of michigan
the plaintiff appellate
now i know that we've talked a number of
facets here of the law but what it comes
down to is a very narrow issue and that
is whether suppression is proper here
and we
in order to decide that issue have to
remember that suppression is a very
extreme remedy it's designed to be a
deterrent against officers who bend the
rules in their quest for justice and to
punish them with unjust acquittal if
they break those rules
so the issue has to be one of examining
whether there was any unreasonableness
on the part of the officer
to defend against suppression we have
three different layers of protection
here first we have the fact that the
officer testified he believed the
defendant was in violation of
257-676-b the impeding traffic statute
the district court disagreed with that
and in doing so had interpreted a
tennessee statute but that kind of goes
against the fundamental principle of
statutory construction and
analysis which is to examine the plain
language of the statute itself our
statute and our statute you know does
not contain any language whatsoever that
says there has to be the active flow of
traffic the specific languages that you
know not block obstruct impede or
otherwise interfere with the normal flow
of vehicular traffic upon republic
street
to interpret
the statute in a manner that's suggested
by the defense is to add language which
is something we can't do as we sit here
and interpret a statute we can't impugn
additional language
based on the clear and unambiguous
language of this statute
there is no requirement that there be an
active flow of traffic
if that were the case then you know we'd
have a whole lot of problems uh whenever
i go down to u of m to watch a football
game i wouldn't have to pay for the
expensive parking i could just throw my
hazards on and park in the middle of the
road as long as there's no active flow
of traffic
that's not what the legislature intended
and to try to interpret it that way
produces an absurd result which is one
of the things we try to avoid when we
talk about
interpreting a statute
you know the statute doesn't refer to an
attempt it doesn't provide any kind of
penalty for an attempt but it does
you know state that
providing any kind of obstruction in the
roadway that doesn't necessarily have to
be a vehicle the statute goes on to
refer to blockades or
you know whether you drag a cinder block
in the middle of the road that can be a
violation of the statute as well
council i i have a question sure i i've
always believed that you always want to
try to keep things simple and practical
so if you could just help me out here
for my practical situation or practical
approach to this
if the defendant wanted to employ his
rights
what is it that he should have done
differently in this case
implore his rights to to to not have to
engage with the officer if he you know
what what is it that he if he you know
basically what is it that he could have
done differently if he wanted to evoke
his rights
if you're talking about at the time of
the stop
yeah i'm talking about the seizure
getting into the issue of the seizure
sure
at the time of the seizure um
you know obviously the standard is would
a reasonable person have felt like their
liberty was constrained and so
uh you know looking at this the totality
of the circumstances this is happening
outdoors it's not in a confined space
it's not
you know with the defendant in handcuffs
it's not the defendant surrounded by
multiple officers
and without he has 360 degrees of egress
that he could take to walk away from the
officer there's just nothing stopping
him at that particular point but is it
your position and again
you know and i totally understand and
totally hear your argument but what i'm
trying to garner is kind of you know
anyone in this room here today
you know who is approached in this
situation
i just want to understand from you
specifically just from a practical
perspective in terms of how this affects
ordinary folks as they kind of go about
their business so i just want to kind of
go back to that question again they're
on the driveway
specifically what should he have done
if he did not allow for us to not be
here today sure if if he had decided he
did not want to interact with the
officer and what could he like and that
and that's why i want you to be specific
specifically if you could share what is
it that he should have done
at that point he could have entered the
home of his friend he could have gotten
back into his car to leave he could have
done a variety of different things uh
you know there there really wasn't any
limit to uh you know prevent him from
from doing anything at that point
because isn't it pretty basic he could
have not answered the question you know
the basic miranda rights that i'm sure
everybody in this room and around the
country is familiar with he had the
right to remain silent
so he didn't have to tell the officer
i don't have a license no on me he
didn't have to tell the officer i have
marijuana in my car he didn't have to
tell the officer i just was drinking 20
minutes ago he didn't have to volunteer
all that information
so if he
whether we'd be here or not or whether
there'd be other cause
for an arrest or not
all he had to do
is not answer the question right
correct this
you know in looking at the totality of
the circumstances it's very clear from
the body language and from the
interaction between the two the
defendant and the officer that this
isn't any kind of interrogation that's
did the officer raise his voice no not
at all did he give any commands to stop
walking or to stay put no it was a
congenial interchange in the driveway
did he have his weapon drawn at at all
was he were there any other officers
present that were surrounding this
individual no just the uh the sergeant
on i asked council this on this country
road
if you wanted to visit a friend and
speak to him or her
what would your normal course be to park
on the street or to park on the driveway
i would think park in the driveway if
this is a acquaintance of yours you
would probably feel more than welcome so
the officer here did what
any ordinary citizen would do if they
wanted to engage
another citizen in conversation is that
right correct
he approached him uh you know and it's
certainly again not an interrogation
that's occurring in the driveway it's
a normal conversation asking him you
know because the officer
is is concerned about what he saw on the
road he thought the behavior was unusual
and so he simply made contact to to
follow up and see if there was a problem
they engaged in
a a casual exchange discussing what he
was doing
and at some point the defendant
volunteered on his own council is it
your position though that the average
person who's joining us here today if
they were in the same situation as the
facts have elucidated
would just feel free to basically walk
away
walk into a house drive away i mean is
that what you i mean i guess my
perspective is is that the people that
are here today
if if you were to ask them if they feel
that they would be able to just simply
drive away
walk away go into a house is that
something that most people feel that
they could do
well that probably varies from person to
person but the standard is whether a
reasonable person would try and that's
exactly so i would say most people that
are with us today would be defined as
reasonable and i guess using that
standard would the people that are here
today
feel that they could just walk away or
drive away well as as justice uh viviano
mentioned the law recognizes there is a
certain amount of pressure whenever we
have contact with police officers and
that that done doesn't in and of itself
create a seizure but
you have to look at the the
circumstances again the totality of the
circumstances whether that reasonable
person what kind of factors location for
instance is one of the factors
referenced in the case law um you know
as opposed to outside in the open like
this case versus
driven away i'm sorry could he have
driven away
you know that i don't know um i mean
there was nothing to prevent him the
officer hadn't commanded him to stop
right but how would he be a vehicle
driven away how would he actually have
done that
the officer is behind him so how would
he have driven what do you have to like
go on the ground like how would he do
that
from a practical standpoint i i don't
know how much room is even in the
driveway it's it's difficult to tell and
i've i've not seen the scene myself to
tell you if this is a extremely wide
driveway that he could have pulled
around him but you know he was he was on
foot he could have gotten into his car
he could have gone into the house he
could have not answered the questions it
this this for all intents and purposes
was just an exchange between two people
and and as the law indicates not every
contact with a police officer amounts to
a seizure for that reason that the idea
is to
you know discourage
you know an interrogation tactic versus
you know precluding all contact between
law enforcement and a citizen council
doesn't make a difference that it wasn't
his house you know i mean i i would
understand the argument if it's like i'm
not talking to you i'm going in my house
now but it wasn't even his house does
that make a difference
it could be one factor you know that but
he's there to visit his friend i would
assume as a friend is expecting him and
probably was free to walk in but
uh again you know there is a whole lot
of you know what ifs that could have
happened that we never get to that point
because
the defendant at some point just
volunteers on his own that he doesn't
have a valid license during the
discussion with the officer and that's
that's when the fourth amendment first
becomes implicated
before we
move over to the discussion of psalters
i want to go back to the uh the statute
and and the plain meaning of the statute
um and when you talked about your
hypothetical i want to give you a
different hypothetical sure um as i'm
driving um to this event in oral
arguments today um the chief justice
calls me and says you know where are you
at on the road and i and i tell her you
know i'm 20 20 minutes out
house traffic
she asks and i say i haven't seen a car
for the last 20 minutes
is there traffic
well i always say if
a stream is empty and i throw a rock
into the middle of the empty stream bed
eventually there's going to be water
there and and i'm obstructing that flow
whether it's active at the time or not
so and i and i
again
it the salters as you pointed to you
know the salters court
agreed with that premise that there's
just simply no language that says that
there has to be that active flow of
traffic and i know it's it's not
published uh it's only persuasive but
it's very persuasive in the sense that
it gives some guidance on this exact
issue
so uh you know i i i
just don't see that there's any language
in that statute neither neither did the
salters court well what what about
estelle
which which
uh was decided after th this um after
salters and after this incident
um that that court did see it
differently
well true but
again just looking at the fundamental
premise behind statutory interpretation
you know
i think if the if the legislature had
intended and i think a lot of statutory
constructionists would agree if the
legislature had intended there to be the
active flow of traffic in order for
there to be a violation they simply
could have added that language well
let's just get to the language of the
statute i think you'd have a much
stronger case if the statute read shall
not block obstruct impede
pedestrian traffic upon a public street
but it doesn't say that it says shall
not block obstruct impede or otherwise
interfere with the normal flow of
vehicular or pedestrian traffic on the
street what what meaning do we give to
the words normal flow of trap of the
traffic
well that's the question is normal flow
mean right now or does it mean in the
future
but doesn't it suggest that there's
actually some impeding going on
well as opposed to impeding or blocking
a public street that's one thing but
when you
when you impede to interrupt the normal
flow of traffic
traffic it seems to me the legislature
wanted there to be some disruption of of
the flow of traffic and there was none
here but it doesn't indicate whether
that has to be active now or in the
future
am i obstructing traffic when i block it
now even though there is no traffic now
that flow of traffic will be
eventually obstructed as normal flow
mean now or does it mean in the future
and that's that's the question and i
think the language is left general
enough
that you can certainly interpret it the
way the salters court did
council here's my question um on the on
the language
if the legislature had said
a person shall not impede
the normal or excuse me shall not impede
the flow
of vehicular
traffic that seems to me all they would
have needed to say
if they intended to mean the actual flow
of traffic or to impede an actual
vehicle
um
why did they add the word normal what
does that add to the equation what does
that add to the mix the fact that they
said you shall not interfere with
the normal or regular
or usual
flow of traffic is that was that a way
of
making this the the scope of the statute
broader i i believe so because normal
flow of traffic
normal can vary from one point in the
day to the next whether
whatever road you might be on uh you
know whether you're on your way to
hillsdale or on your way to chicago
so
you know that i believe was left broad
enough so that it could
you know encompass people who
deliberately create an impediment and
and decide i'm going to put a barricade
across two lanes of a highway even
though there's no traffic right now
because i want to be a jerk and i want
to block the flow of traffic so if
you're driving your combine
down a country road
during a time of the day where the usual
flow of traffic is very light
you'd be unlikely
to violate this statute would that be
correct
have a correct assumption
well
if it's not heavily as long as the
vehicle is still moving i would say you
were not violating the enemy i'm
guessing you're you're you don't your
your deputies in in in your county
don't spend all their time ticketing
farmers
for driving their farm tractors around
do they no no they don't deal with their
big bales of hay up there when i come up
to portland it's part of the cost of
doing business in the country yes right
council if we're gonna like looking at
particular individual words of the
statute what are we to make of the fact
that it says by means of a barricade
object or device
or with his or her person
not specifying a vehicle which clearly
the legislature knew how to do if that's
what it was and then the the following
sentence talks about uh cons you know
persons maintaining rearranging
constructing public utility or streetcar
facilities
in or adjacent to a street or highway
what are we to make of the fact that
there is not a specific reference to a
vehicle when clearly
that could have been specific i think
you you suggest that your opposing
counsel is adding words to the statute
why are you not adding vehicle to the
statute
again they left it broad enough so that
it it includes anything not just
vehicles
it goes back to what i example i gave if
i'm you know an angry
you know old man and i decide that you
know i think there's too much traffic on
my side street and i decide in the
middle of the night to drag two cement
barricades out in the middle of my road
so that traffic well the barricades are
specifically mentioned so it doesn't say
any with anything possible or right it
says barricades
object device
his or her person
what if somebody had a cow
in the road would that qualify as well
yes if they just let the animals sit
there they have created
what barricade what what
does it be
like i said you know a barricade could
be a variety of different things it
doesn't have to be a cement barrier it
could be any
object that you put in the middle of the
road that acts as a barricade
the the problem is if we interpret this
to mean that
you know you have to have an actual flow
of traffic at the time for there to be a
violation is this old man who decides to
block off his road because he's angry at
all the kids going up and down his road
there's no consequence to him for this
what what violation of law has he
committed then if he hasn't violated
this statute
with blocking the flow of traffic just
because there isn't any traffic on the
road at 2am when he puts those
barricades up can you
you mentioned earlier that the officer
you know believed the statute was
violated and that was reasonable and
we've talked here that there are
um you know there's assaulter opinion
there's other court of appeals opinion
that interpret it differently
what is the guard rail that you think
exists under the law to
to
safeguard
in this from a situation where the
officer
says i you know i thought it was i
thought it was violated even though
yeah and then and that's really you know
that third tier against suppression kind
of the alamo so to speak is that here we
are
as
learned attorneys and judges debating
what this statute means but we've got a
road deputy who believed from his
knowledge and experience as a certified
road patrol officer that this statute
was being violated by what he saw
and and certainly that meets the very
definition of a reasonable mistake
because even we don't know is that is
that analysis though the
whether or not
this uh evidence should be excluded
under the exclusionary rule which really
isn't
it's sort of mentioned in passing under
but but the court of appeals and the
lower courts never really got to that
right
so so even let's say that we we
disagree with you and we find um for the
defendant in this situation
doesn't does the trial court still have
um
work to do on on whether or not this
should be
this nonetheless shouldn't be suppressed
well the the trial court actually issued
an opinion where it found because
there was no violation of the statute
that the evidence should be suppressed
and therefore no admissible evidence was
admitted at the time of the bind over
request and that's why bindover was
denied
the trial court never even gave any
credence to the argument that was made
in briefs about whether well if the
statute wasn't violated was it
reasonable a mistake on the part of the
officer and his suppression still
warranted the court just focused on
whether or not the statute was violated
and so that's why we appealed was
because there was just no discussion uh
in regards to well
say that is true and that that statute
wasn't violated
is the mistake reasonable or not and is
suppression still warrant
the court of appeals didn't address that
question no no i'm talking about in the
trial court right
one more question before i let you sit
down
if we're if we're doing a um
an analysis of whether if if we viewed
it as a mistake of law and whether it's
reasonable can you help me
operationalize that um
the majority in heinz
uh instruction that
reasonable mistake of law should be more
protective of the suspect than a
qualified immunity analysis what is what
work does that do in this case if any
i you know i don't think it it factors
in here because again we come back to
the issue of whether suppression should
occur is you know what is our goal in
suppression here to punish
unreasonable behavior well what behavior
of this officer is unreasonable at the
end of the day he believes the statute's
violated he acts on that if he's wrong
it's still a reasonable mistake of law
because his continued
interaction with the defendant is
nothing more but the definition of
reasonable it's a it's a casual exchange
that only implements the fourth
amendment at the time the defendant
brings up a violation of michigan law
thank you council thank you
[Music]
uh to clarify so how do you get around
the question as to
your client didn't have to speak to the
officer or answer questions
the totality of the circumstance in the
situations blocked in a driveway
ends up saying he does not have his id
on him
and in addition to that justice
bernstein
we're presuming
that mr lucinski could walk into his
friend's house he didn't know that his
friend was there or not there they had
conversation i guess day or two before
he may be coming by so he couldn't just
walk into the house and then
you know wait for the police to not come
up but in addition to that the statute
does not list a car because a vehicle
can actually be moved
but under the the seizure it was
definitely a seizure that occurred in
the driveway because mr lesinski
couldn't
move out there in a way that would be
safe or would be reasonable
if you had a concluding remark you may
make it we kept your opposing counsel up
a little extra
i'm going to reiterate what i have said
before madam chief justices if it
doesn't interfere with the normal flow
then the traffic stop in this
circumstance
should be let go
thank you thank you both the case will
be submitted
oh
testing
good morning everyone
my name is dan brubacher i'm the chief
commissioner of the michigan supreme
court um normally i would be doing this
kind of next section of the program
which is what we call the student
debriefing uh but fortunately for you
today we have a very very special guest
who will be taking that over from me his
name
his name will be familiar to some of you
it's justice steven markman
justice markman served as a u.s attorney
he was on the michigan court of appeals
for for a number of years and then he
was on the michigan supreme court from
1999
to 2020 uh two of those years he served
as the chief justice and i got to work
with him very closely during those years
uh and i know that he's also very proud
to be a professor of constitutional law
here at your very own hillsdale
to be honest i could spend easily spend
at least 20 minutes going over
the
listing justice markman's amazing
accomplishments uh in his storied legal
career uh but i'm not going to do that
um i did want to mention for instance
though that
one thing that i googled him in order to
prepare for this one thing that really
impressed me you
you may not know that he helped draft
the constitution of the ukraine
and he is currently
working on it with through a european
union commission
uh working with the chief justice of the
supreme court of the ukraine to
establish an independent judiciary in
that country
uh so just a couple of little things i
would mention i'm not going to go on
because the longer i went on uh the more
he would probably get embarrassed and
eventually just pull me off the stage
and i don't want that to happen but it's
i think that's a testament to the kind
of person he is
so without further ado i would like to
bring you the debriefer for today
justice stephen markman
and
the attorneys i think if you would bring
your chairs
up to the stage we can have you or you
could just sit at the table here and i
think then
after justice markman's remarks you'll
be able to answer the questions from the
audience
[Music]
hello can you hear me well
thank you
um thank you very much for the
introduction dan
dan brubacher is the chief commissioner
once again of the michigan supreme court
he's been that for many years
and he is quite likely the most
knowledgeable person about
michigan law of anybody in the state of
michigan
and of course an expert on the cases
that are appearing before this court
um
the seven justices
who were here a few moments ago are now
presumably
conferencing about the one case that
they've heard this morning
they're discussing it and their
attitudes about the case and um
probably questions they asked and
questions they might have asked and
questions they they should have asked
but they're doing so in order to
ascertain what their initial
perspectives are
on this case and whether for example
there's a majority position that's been
established among the seven justices and
whether there's also a majority for a
particular analysis in favor
of whatever result there might be a
majority on in other words whether
they're inclined to affirm the court of
appeals
to sustain what the court of appeals has
done which is in favor of the prosecutor
in this case or whether they want to
reverse
what the court of appeals has done and
thereby act in favor of the defendant in
this case but they have a variety of
other options they might undertake as
well
including simply saying we shouldn't
have heard this case so we're going to
we're going to
end our participation and let the court
of appeals judgment be sustained or we
want to hear
more arguments or we want more
information from the
advocates in this case they have a wide
variety of options that they can
undertake here
therefore an order could be issued
within a matter of days
or a thorough opinion could be issued
but not until after several months have
elapsed it's
anybody's guess right now but the court
presumably is discussing the options
that are available to it
as you know what you've heard this
morning is part of
the supreme court's once or twice a year
visit to a location outside of lansing
typically to an educational institution
as they're doing today
where the appellate part of the judicial
process can be presented to students
the trial part of the
legal process i think is much more
evident and
and familiar to most people because they
see tv and film presentations but the
appellate process
is something that's a lot more hidden
the appellate process is of course in a
nutshell that there is a trial before a
single judge a trial a circuit judge a
probate judge a district judge
and the losing party in that process
generally has an entitlement to a right
to an appeal
to try to correct what he or she or it
views as the mistakes that took place at
the trial process
and
that appeal to try to correct the
alleged errors would take place before a
court of appeals
where you no longer have one trial judge
but you have three appellate judges
and the loser at that stage of the
process
does not have a right to an appeal but
they have an opportunity to an appeal
before the supreme court which is the
highest court of the state of michigan
almost every case that the michigan
supreme court hears including the one
that they've heard this morning is at
their discretion
there's no entitlement by and large to
an appeal before the michigan supreme
court
i know that the court would extend its
appreciation to everyone here at
hillsdale for their efforts in
facilitating this argument as well as to
the two attorneys who've consented to
allow this case to be heard in a very
unorthodox setting before the students
here at hillsdale
so now we're going to have about 20 or
25 minutes for questions before we head
to the reception
and during that time
i will call on you and hope that you
have some questions for the
uh for the two attorneys in this case
um
before we do that though i'd like to ask
one
introductory question of a prosecutor
winning and counsel jokim
and it's a fairly obvious question but i
think it's an important threshold
question
and that is
why in your opinion
among the 200 or so appeals that are
filed from all 83 counties around
michigan each month
did the court
exercise its discretion in this case in
other words why was this case among the
two or three percent of all the cases
that are appealed to the michigan
supreme court
that drew a full oral argument of the
sort that you saw this morning why this
case
if i could ask the prosecutor first of
all well thank you justice uh
you know as a prosecutor um you know
we're dealing primarily with criminal
law and criminal law focuses on the
fourth fifth and sixth amendments to the
u.s and michigan constitutions
this particular case is ripe with all
kinds of issues with regards to the
fourth amendment and it has to do with
statutory interpretation which is a
fundamental part of what lawyers do the
legislature drafts the law for us
then it's up to us as attorneys to
interpret that to fit the particular
situation and so when we were talking
about statutory construction we were
talking about
rules that guide us as attorneys and as
judges to try to interpret what the
legislature intended when they used that
specific language
and so you have just a a litany of
different
areas that this case covered there were
three main focuses of today's arguments
and one had to do with
the statutory interpretation
the other had to do with the fourth
amendment
and the other had to do with whether or
not uh you know
we as ordinary citizens are interactions
with law enforcement in the community
and you know what what limitations are
there
at what point do we become
the subject of a criminal case at what
point do we shift from an ordinary
contact between two citizens to one
between a law enforcement member and a
suspect so
i think that was
one of the reasons why this case was
selected because there were just so many
different aspects related to the fourth
amendment and to whether the evidence in
this case should have been suppressed or
not let me ask defense counsel defense
counsel joking the same question please
uh thank you uh justice markman uh i
believe that eric hit a lot of things uh
right on on point and from my aspect as
as a defender there's not much more
sacred than our constitutional rights in
particular the fourth the fifth and
sixth amendment that you're not entitled
to unreasonable searches and seizures
that you have a right to remain silent
and that you have uh you know your right
to counsel
and in this circumstance i mean we could
have probably had
i mean maybe this is going to be uh an
exam question this would be a great khan
law question this would be a great
criminal procedure question that you
could probably have
a whole entire bar exam in different
areas and just have them under different
aspects i i totally believe that and
when i came across this i'm like okay
does this stop good like i don't think
this stop is right and then
talking to to eric when we were going
through this thing
well i don't think there was a stop i
don't think there was a seizure and like
wow these are
a lot of things that were going on and
case law that was un
defined
in addition to that this is was
completely unchartered territory and
what we kind of have is this is based
upon a statute that was very specific
and it was probably
set for um
i mean you could you could read it
everyone could take the time for
impeding traffic it's 257.676
and it says the the normal flow of
traffic and it also mentions these
buzzwords like protester or barricades
and things of that nature so it's it's
my opinion this was set up
for to kind of disperse protests but
this whole thing this was just so many
issues between the fourth the fifth and
the sixth amendment that needed to be
answered that
i've
i'm being honest i thought that this was
one out of the gate and i think that
eric and i actually said this is
probably
something that's going to be decided
at a much higher court and
i really thought that these issues were
the legal term would be ripe and also
very important it affects everyone
everyone in this room because you know
at the end of the day you can't just
take the constitution and pick the parts
you like
okay could i ask the students who'd like
to ask a question to please come to one
of the microphones here
and direct your question uh as
appropriate and
we'll ask typically that
each of our two council uh respond but
we'd ask them to do so
with the relative
concision so that we can get as many
questions in as possible would somebody
like to to move to one of the
microphones
why don't you please move to the
microphone we can't hear you
and other others who'd like to line up
please don't hesitate to do it at the
other microphone
um hello uh i wanted to ask a question
to like clarify some of the case itself
is that okay a little confused about
um i wanted to know what the um
defendant was actually like doing that
caused the officer to drive into the
driveway and like try to stop him and
what was like counted as an actual like
impeding traffic because that was
something that was please please brief
again responding so we don't re-argue
the entire case in the next few minutes
we could do this all day even a lawyer
of the floor can be done now the uh the
case started with the officer who was on
patrol and he came across the defendant
who is sitting in the middle of the road
in his vehicle sitting driver side to
driver's side with a vehicle facing in
the opposite direction it was two
gentlemen just having a conversation in
the middle of the road but as he was
coming up you know they created a
they blocked that entire road he wasn't
able to get around but as he approached
they saw that he was a patrol car and
they eventually
moved and he pulled into a driveway just
down the road
council oh they're um
that's not an inaccurate uh
representation as as to what went down
but uh there was no traffic of
my my guy my client i was saying my guy
i don't like to use the term client you
know my my guy my person uh he wasn't
doing anything there was there was
fictitious traffic so
uh
you know they ended up getting uh a
charge out of that dui charge
so
thank you for the question
thank you
now we have a number of judges here from
hillsdale surrounding counties and
understand again that every one of the
cases the michigan supreme court hears
is initiated at the trial court level
and the one
thing that's true about almost every
case heard by every trial court judge in
this state is that there's a winner and
a loser
we wish everyone could be a winner but
it just doesn't typically work out that
way
and
remember once again the loser has a
right to appeal to the michigan court of
appeals in which there are three judges
but regrettably there's also a loser at
that stage of the process and a winner
and the loser has the opportunity to
seek it up to seek an appeal before the
michigan supreme court
please
so i have
two questions
you said that the officer came up and
observed them
while they were stopped
and you say that that's the violation of
the law why didn't he stop them then
rather than following him all the way
even though they moved away he
he observed them violating the law so
why didn't he turn on his lights
and stop him there rather than waiting
until he was parked
that's a great question
you're going first eric well what did
what had happened was the officer was
coming down
this this road and he observed this and
before he got to them they had moved on
and separated because i think they saw
that there was a patrol car coming and
and then he moved just a few you know
not very far down the road and into this
driveway of his friend
so
you know the officer really didn't have
a chance to you know
throw on the overhead lights and run the
sirens or anything like that but the
officer
uh
what he was doing was what we call in
our line of work community caretaker
function which is you know just making
sure everything's okay sometimes
officers have interactions with citizens
because they see something that's
peculiar maybe he was having car trouble
or or there was uh you know some other
issue so he made contact with him he
didn't effectuate a stop so to speak
because he he didn't turn on his lights
he didn't uh you know come out with his
gun drawn or anything like that he
basically was checking on him to see
what was going on and then as they were
talking
you know that's when
that's when things kind of went south
for the defend
there was a reason why the emergency
lights weren't on when
my
guy and the other car
were next to each other
because they weren't interrupting the
oral flow of traffic
there was no reason to turn on the
emergency lights
so that that's why that didn't go down
and as i do agree with some of the
things that uh
uh eric had had mentioned yes there's a
community caretaker you know unofficial
provision in every county in tuscola
county
is very
zealous they're very serious about that
but at the same time that doesn't mean
that we should be chipping away against
our rights the fourth the fifth and
sixth amendment and which
sadly
in my humble opinion
the set of facts
seems to
do
can we please move on to another
question we're gonna have a lot of
questions here i think
go on please
so i understand that this defense's
position that there was a seizure as
soon as the police car pulled into the
driveway but i mean my question i guess
would be to the prosecution
do you agree with that
um portrayal of it was it an
investigative stop was it a seizure was
it just a conversation and what's the
delineation between those different
things
sure well the fourth amendment comes
into play when there is an effect a
seizure and until that time that the
defendant mentions to the officer during
this five minute conversation they had
leading up to it that he didn't have a
valid license well the officer knew he
had just seen him driving so at that
point the officer has what's called
probable cause to detain him for a
violation of the law for driving without
a valid license
that's the first time a seizure could
take place that's the first time any
violation of the law that would require
him to seize the defendant occurs before
that you know there's really nothing
much going on i mean yes technically he
violated the statute for impeding
traffic which is a citation only
but
at that point he doesn't have to issue
that citation you know his inquiry is
you know what what's going on is there a
problem that i should be aware of
council
that's a good looking suit man
it is you look better than a lot of the
attorneys that
come into a lot of the courthouses i go
into and the pocket square is cool too
um so you're asking about the the
seizure in in in the driveway well
again you know uh you know my my
adversary my uh colleague you know has
his version a way i see is a little bit
different
mr lesinski didn't feel that he was free
to leave
you know there's a it's not just one
thing and we had all these hypotheticals
where it could go into house he could
have just walked away he could have
gotten his card and you know laid a
gummy and and driven away too
but didn't do that so it's a series of
things you know is the vehicle blocking
in the circumstance and then you know
giving the invalid driver's license and
at that point
it could have been placed under arrest
as a seizure and that would have been
and there's ways that you can search a
vehicle incident to lawful arrest with
the inventory policies which every
law enforcement agency generally they're
supposed to have so
up at that point you know if there is a
seizure that's when you know he wasn't
free to leave your argument but a lot of
this stuff is very
theoretical it could go anyway but
that's you know my you know version as
to what went down
these two just can't seem to agree with
each other
please imagine that go ahead
i have a pretty general question but why
did the officer choose to follow the
defendant instead of the other car
and did the other car also receive a
citation
no unfortunately there wasn't
multiple units out there so they really
couldn't divide and conquer
he ended up behind the defendant because
the defendant was traveling the same
lane of travel as him so he
he ended up following him into the
driveway because they were going the
same direction
well there was a reason why he didn't
pull over the other car because it would
not have been so easy to turn around
just like on the the dirt road that's
here i i want to say it's east car but
you know it's you go one lane one
direction one in the other direction
so
i can't think for off deputy robinson
but from
my deductive logic well i'll just
continue to follow this car and see what
happens i believe that that's what went
down because there was there would have
been a reason for the stop then the
lights would have went on
thank you the question i'd just like to
emphasize that this case is going to be
resolved in all likelihood
on the basis as it should be of what the
statute says here so make sure that each
of you take a close look at the statute
here to try to figure out uh the extent
to which it's applicable to the present
circumstances and what precisely its
language means or doesn't mean in the
end as all my ju
as all the judges here know
the results of this case
the rule of law is determined not by us
looking into our own individual
consciences but looking to the law that
guides the issue that's in dispute
please
could the officer be considered traffic
you want to answer that one first there
the officer uh
when he pulls him over
he's driving down the road oh yes oh yes
yes well yes arguably he could be
considered traffic yes
uh you know he is a car that is trying
to pass through that particular area and
he did testify that he was una he would
have been unable to get around this
vehicle until it moved so
the empty riverbed has water in it
apparently apparently
and here's the funny thing now um
you know mentioning that as to
why the
the stop had or had not occurred
you know as far as what traffic is
concerned
if the officer would have been coming
from the other direction or if he would
have been close or trying to get behind
then there could have been argument for
that in my humble opinion however
unambiguously
in court records it indicates that
deputy robinson was over 800 feet
behind
the the cars
so
there was no traffic to be impeded
thank you for the question
thank you thank you thank you
yes sir
uh why did you specifically take this
case for both
well
as the prosecutor we we charge
violations of michigan law and
ultimately what was discovered after the
seizure took place and the defendant
admitted he didn't have a valid license
is there was further discussion that
resulted in him admitting that he had
used
marijuana recently he'd been drinking
recently and so then the officer engaged
in further investigation there in the
driveway as to whether he was
able to drive legally at the time and
then ultimately his blood was you know
drawn after arrest and confirmed that he
would have been under the influence so
that's why we charged the violation of
the statute under the motor vehicle call
and i'll tell you why i got involved
this was an appointed case
practice is appointed work and it's
retained work and i think that that's
important and that's not something i'm
ready to get rid of
and
procedurally this got suppressed in
district court and then it was con
affirmed in circuit
and then i remember after the hearing
i'm i'm not using your exact words
but you'd indicated that you're
appealing this because you don't think
this is good policy
so eric had won in in the court of
appeals and i have this theory and i
encourage every all the students to use
this when making important decisions
if it's something that that you remember
in the middle of a hard workout a good
two three times
then it's something that's important
that you should roll with
and this bugged the heck out of me on a
long run and a couple workouts so i just
couldn't let it go
so i'm not
man uh what is the role that you see the
court is playing or does play or in your
opinion should play in like legislative
um
intent like we saw that the statue a lot
of the justices were questioning that i
believe the actual language was like a
barricade object person or device and
there's push back that it didn't specify
a vehicle and then the prosecution was
saying it could be included what is the
role that the court is supposed to play
in saying this is what the legislative
intended or this is what they should
have said but this needs to be addressed
on the law making level not the
judiciary level sure
um you know the as i mentioned during
the argument the the fundamental rule of
interpreting a statute is to just simply
read that language and read it in a
common sense manner and and do your best
to try to understand what that intent
was based on that language they the
court is not allowed to to add language
because that's called legislating from
the bench so they have that separation
of powers that you all learn about in
school with regards to
judicial and executive and legislative
so one can't interfere with the other so
that's one of the roles of the bench
in the judicial is to
use what it's been given and not add to
that to determine well what did the what
did the legislature intend to accomplish
here
when they created this statute there's a
way that you could find out some of this
information though
as far as like what i'm asking for in my
posture i'm not asking for anything to
be i'm asking for the statute to be
interpreted the way that it was written
however i have theories as to why it was
written that i indicated in my in my
argument and since you mentioned
legislative intent which is a buzzword
to me that you actually care and you
actually want to know what's going on
and maybe you'll even be a future lawyer
so
there there's a case
that uh in connecticut where they
debunked their possession of marijuana
law and they did it because it was based
upon racism and the only way that they
found that is they had to go back into
the old microfiches into like the 40s
and 50s
so that's the type of thing that
legislative intent would be more if
you're trying to like really go after
something constitutionality in this
circumstance
i think it was for to debunk protests
and gatherings that might have been
considered unruly and a lot of times you
know people are just written
the ticket for it because it's under the
motor vehicle code because that's
supposed to protect the public at large
in motor vehicles
thank you
thank you for being here i have a
question for mr wanik you refer to a
tennessee law in your argument and i was
wondering why that applied given this
was a michigan statute sure well um
it was
the at the lower court level the
judge we had what was called a
preliminary hearing that's the first
stage in a felony prosecution where we
have to establish probable cause of the
crimes committed and the defendant
committed
you have to present legally admissible
evidence at this hearing and the judge
ruled that our evidence was not legally
admissible because he felt that the
statute should not have been construed
in the way that i was suggesting
and in order to get there to interpret
it as he did he focused on a tennessee
statute in a case that interpreted a
tennessee law now in reviewing that
tennessee law it actually
refers to slow moving vehicles causing
an impediment in other words driving too
slow on a highway michigan has its own
equivalent of that uh that
basic speed law it's called
and so
you know my position is it was more akin
to that statute than our impeding
traffic which has to do with stationary
objects being in the middle of the road
and
but the fundamental tenets that i was
arguing to the to the bench here today
of statutory construction is you have to
interpret the language of our statute
not incorporate an interpretation of a
tennessee law
uh and in in looking at our language
from our statute i think it can only be
read one way so yeah the funny thing
about the about the tennessee case the
hannah case which judge bitzer was very
thorough and the tennessee court was
very thorough in reaching their opinion
because they
they dissected eight different statutes
and then they talk about their language
and then that was mirrored as well in
the opinion and that was mirrored in uh
some of the briefs that were filed with
the pertinent courts
so
and in that circumstance
you know that's not something you would
call persuasive
argument and it was
i think that it's uh appropriate to look
at it in this circumstance because it's
not asking for anything to be added it
was doing it out of analogy
parallel and it was pretty thorough
thank you for the question
just for those of you who don't know
could i ask to counsel here to just very
very
concisely explain what the exclusionary
rule is and what the good faith
exception to the exclusionary rule is it
means defenders always get ganked around
and and why those concepts are relevant
to this case
the exclusionary rule is a rule that
basically is designed it's created by
the judiciary to punish officers who
might bend the rules in order to
as i put this morning seek justice
sometimes
officers can be overzealous they may not
may cut corners they may do things that
they shouldn't in order to get
statements or seize evidence that they
otherwise wouldn't have been able to get
if they had followed the rules and the
purpose of the exclusionary rule is to
punish officers who do bend the rules by
basically taking the evidence out of
play and leaving the officer's case with
no evidence which pretty much results in
an acquittal for the defendant so it's
it's a it's a very heavy-handed remedy
though it's designed to punish officers
who very clearly
violated the law in order to
obtain the evidence or obtain a
statement from a defendant and the good
faith exception basically is designed to
have the bench take a second look at an
officer's actions whether it be
factually what they did or the loss
as they understood it
and if the officer acted in a certain
way or or based on an interpretation of
the law that he felt
said a certain or should be read a
certain way even if it turns out he's
mistaken after the fact his actions are
still reasonable they aren't
unreasonable he wasn't trying to cut
corners he wasn't trying to break rules
it just turns out he was wrong and the
law basically says under under that
good faith is that
we don't penalize officers who just make
mistakes we penalize officers who
knowingly break the rules
and so
exclusion of the evidence doesn't occur
when the mistake is reasonable
the exclusionary rule this would come
from i believe that came and
came into play from was under justice
scalia
and it's something that does protect law
enforcement in many ways and there's
nothing that's more sobering than
having a full-blown evidentiary hearing
addressing a fourth amendment issue and
then having a judge say yes this was a
violation
however
you know this was good faith so we're
not suppressing it so
the good faith exception
it's supposed to
be another level if something is either
inadvertent unintentional if it was
something that's considered
reasonable a reasonable mistake and
clearly in this circumstance i don't
think that the officers
i don't think the mistake was reasonable
sir
um so both of you seem to be very
passionate about this case and uh
i would just like to know why you were
so
opinionated about it so uh
opinionated yeah me
so you specifically you uh did one about
the combine
right driving through the road and uh
you did one about an angry old man that
put in cinder blocks or something like
that in the middle of the road
and i can't use opinions in my class we
have to go through arguments and every
now and then and if i can't use
opinionated
statements against my fellow classmates
how did you expect it to work here
well
i look at the opinions as more of a our
role as attorneys is to advocate we
advocate on behalf of our clients he his
client is the defendant my client is the
people the state of michigan so we we
advocated zealously as we can and our
opinions are are based on the law as we
interpret we have to support those
opinions with case law or statutes
otherwise as you indicated our opinions
really don't mean anything so you know
we're allowed to express our beliefs on
what the law says
based on our interpretation of it and
advocate a particular position uh and
argue for a particular goal and outcome
so
uh in my particular case uh you know the
example you mentioned you know i i used
that to highlight the fact that you know
if in my view that statute is created to
prevent something just like that
occurring and and if if this statute
doesn't cover that then what's the
penalty to somebody who does this so
that was sort of the point i was trying
to allude to and and advocating for that
position
friends don't let friends get haircuts
we're on the same page
but
but seriously
um the the combine example
when i was driving when i was driving in
here yesterday there was there was a lot
of rural roads and i can't remember the
name of it i have it in my notes
somewhere i want to say it's like east
car
and
if there would have been a combine there
if i went when i had stopped for a
minute arguably that could have been
something that would have impeding
traffic going from one of the other
areas
but
you know just to
under the idea that
traffic could be impeded in the future
which i believe that this is a lot of
where the government's case is coming
from i don't think that that that flies
i mean it has to be actual impeding
traffic and then through that analogy i
mean that's the best one in which i
could have thought of that would have
been relevant on the community standard
because if you look at the statute that
essentially says normal flow which
really breaks it down to community
standard you know normal flow is going
to be different in hillsdale than it is
in my backyard in lapeer or you know
downtown on woodward in detroit city
thank you for the question
i would say also that the matter of
civil and constitutional liberties and
criminal punishments and the criminal
justice system and how we give meaning
to the law are all matters that are
properly
matters of passion on the part of
advocates um
of the sort that we've seen this morning
so i think
typically the arguments that we see
involve
attorneys who are passionate and who
feel strongly about an issue and i think
if any one of you your family or your
neighbors became involved in the justice
system in some way you would want a
lawyer an advocate who felt passionately
in favor of the
positions that you were urging or urging
against please
i think
i was going to call on her but you want
me to call on her first right thank you
okay go on please
okay so um
they're really good points made i
definitely saw both sides really well um
but i was caught on a little point
justice bernstein had made um he brought
up like the pressure felt by most
citizens when talking to a uniformed
officer i do see and understand where
that would come from however wouldn't he
uh your client or your guy um as a
reasonable reasonable person feel
pressure if anybody had pulled in behind
him and asked him like if they could ask
him a couple questions i do see like i
completely understand we all check
ourselves like when we're driving we see
a cop car like how fast am i going am i
buckled like we all do that
but specifically when the police are
involved we have more rights like not to
speak to them or to like keep to
ourselves or not say anything with the
rights to remain silent outlined in the
miranda rights my my question was more
of i wonder how you can think an officer
without lights or sirens or whatnot how
do you think that affected him more in
the case as opposed to like any other
person it could have been a friend of
his or just a random stranger who
happened to be driving behind him
sure and and it is different you know as
the justices alluded to having contact
with the police automatically heightens
anybody's you know perceptions of you
know this is this is important
and uh it is different than an ordinary
citizen but in the end until you know
you're in violation of law of the law
an officer has no right to seize you so
any interaction he has with you is
nothing more than a congenial
interaction no different than any
citizen even if he is wearing a badge in
a uniform
so the defendant in that case i know you
mentioned miranda rights miranda rights
come into play with an interrogation
once someone is identified as a suspect
and they are questioned in that capacity
then your miranda rights come into play
but just walking up to an ordinary
citizen on the street that's not an
interrogation that that's just a simple
interaction it could be investigatory
questioning uh such as you know is there
a problem did your car break down you
know why were you guys just sitting
there in the middle of the road he has a
right to ask those questions just like
anybody else
that that's a good question so
this goes to a
reasonable person standard you know just
the average person average human being
uh would that person have felt free to
leave i would have felt uncomfortable if
i would have pulled into someone's
driveway and there had been a police car
behind me regardless if the emergency
lights were on or not and then if a
policeman
woman
would have confronted me i would have
more than likely engaged and i've been
practicing law for
a couple minutes
and if i felt that way a little way and
if i felt nervous the way that you do
and you follow the law
than you can only imagine in in that
circumstance
and uh you had another part of your
question too
um there was another part of your
question that you had as well
it was just like about like the pressure
that one would feel as in like if he had
been able to pull out would you feel
more pressured to go in the grass if it
was an officer as opposed to anyone else
it wouldn't have been a natural
movement
and
you know i think that that would have
been it would have been difficult and
that's part of the reason why he didn't
feel the free to leave
and then as mr wanik had said before
miranda doesn't kick in until it's a
custodial interrogation which good chunk
of the time a person is arrested
however
there's also about 11 factors that go
along with that that i know that justice
marcus has seen
numerous times over his his long career
and that mr wanick has seen as well
there's literally like 11 factors it's
not just one thing
thank you for that let's do our last
question now please try to do it as
briefly as we can i will thank you
um just a clarification question
actually do you believe i remember in
the defense part of the argumentative
phase
a lot of emphasis was put on how the
accused would feel if they were
approached by an officer especially in
uniform and there were a lot of
follow-up questions was this in accord
coordination with the exclusion law just
trying to clarify whether or not the
police officer was being hostile and
acting in good faith
sure um
you know they like we argued the just
the simple interaction with the officer
uh didn't amount to a seizure and
you know the exclusionary rule applies
if the seizure is unlawful
so the whole issue we were arguing today
is at what point does that seizure take
place
and you know our position that we
advocated today was that the seizure
takes place when the defendant first
mentions five minutes into the
conversation oh yeah i don't have a
valid license he just volunteers that
information
that is when the fourth amendment will
come into play that is when you
determine whether that seizure if the
officer placed him under arrest at that
point whether that was a lawful seizure
because then if it is anything any
evidence he gains after that fact
would not be subject to exclusion
because it was a lawful seizure but if
it was unlawful you know then
any evidence that comes about as a
result of a a unlawful seizure that gets
excluded it's uh
pretty much from the unlawful seizure to
the end of the case no matter how much
evidence has been seized it could all be
tossed out it's what's called the fruit
of the poisonous tree that may be a term
you you've heard but
but it's a it's a legal concept that
basically says
from the moment that violation of the
law occurs on the part of the officer
any work he did from that moment on
sorry none of that evidence comes in
so
really it comes down to because most of
our evidence in this case
was
was seized or or collected after that
statement is made
and then through further discussion he
not only finds he's he's suspended but
he finds that you know he can smell
marijuana on him he can smell alcohol on
it so then he starts questioning him
well if you had anything to drink today
if you use any marijuana if so how long
ago
and i think he said he'd been fishing a
few minutes before that and
consumed out on the ice which i get it i
mean you know
fishing can be boring you know but um
in any event so but that all that
evidence including the blood that's
drawn from him you know from that moment
on could be subject to suppression if
that moment in time is determined to be
unlawful mr yokum
i'll be very brief
exclusionary rule that's
an accurate representation of it and the
the old case which we all go back to
it's called wong sung the fruit of the
poisonous tree so if something was
unreasonable in this as our scotus or
the supreme court has held
then
that should be suppressed and then that
would not meet the the good faith
exception the good faith exception is
supposed to uh
protect you know reasonable police
worker there's a reasonable mistake and
my argument is
seizure occurred when the officer pulled
into the driveway behind
and then anything after that should be
suppressed
thank you for the question thank you all
for your participation today i thank
both council for their insights um i
hope this has been an instructive
experience and um i hope it'll be
a further instructive as we proceed to
the reception because i know the
justices and the
council here will be more than glad to
discuss
some of these matters with you further
but you do need to understand of course
that the justices are not going to be
able to share their
deepest views on this case right now
they'll have to speak to those later on
but in terms of the procedures and what
you've witnessed today
i hope you will engage them and i'm sure
they'll be
appreciative of the opportunity to
respond so thank you once again thank
you to hillsdale for your hospitality
today
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
once again i want to thank all of you
for being here students we hope this
inspires you in many ways we hope it
inspires you to be good law abiding
citizens we hope it also maybe inspires
some of you to think about going into
the field of law these things are
important we need good people
that consider such an occupation
next we have a reception hillsdale
college has been kind enough to provide
a reception for the students it's going
to be out here and then some of the
people in the room have been invited to
a special luncheon you're going to go up
the stairs and check in at that table so
thank you i hope you enjoy the rest of
your day
you